el siguiente órgano accesorio del tracto
gastrointestinal del que vamos a hablar
es el hígado el hígado es este órgano
gordo que tenemos aquí tiene que ser uno
de los órganos más geniales del cuerpo
es el único del que puedes tomar una
parte este pedacito de aquí y
trasplantar la a un receptor que tenga
cirrosis o insuficiencia hepática y
puede crecer hasta convertirse en un
órgano mucho más grande que puede
sostener al paciente que tan loco es eso
para comprender mejor el funcionamiento
del hígado comenzaremos por discutir las
principales funciones de las que es
responsable lo primero que debemos
pensar es que es responsable del
metabolismo eso implica la
descomposición de nutrientes o
catabolismo así como la síntesis de
macromoléculas más grandes y esas a
través del anabolismo de modo que el
catabolismo y el anabolismo se logran en
el hígado la otra función de la que el
hígado es responsable es el
almacenamiento de estos nutrientes
cuando no estamos descomponiendo o
sintetizando estos nutrientes
necesitamos tener un
para que permanezcan durante un rato y
el hígado es responsable del
almacenamiento de nuestros carbohidratos
así que escribiré carbohidratos y
principalmente de nuestros lípidos y
estos dos se almacenan de tres maneras
diferentes primero los carbohidratos y
lípidos se pueden almacenar como
glucógeno el glucógeno es solo un
polisacárido por lo que es un enlace de
muchos monosacáridos o azúcares simples
la otra forma cómo podemos almacenar
nuestros carbohidratos y nuestros
lípidos es como lipoproteínas lipo
significa grasa y proteínas y por último
también las podemos almacenar como
triglicéridos que es una de las formas
de lípidos que ingerimos en nuestra
comida ahora estas son dos de las
principales macromoléculas que usamos
para la energía la otra clase importante
de macromoléculas que ve el hígado son
las proteínas pero en realidad no se
almacenan en el hígado en cambio se
procesan en macromoléculas como la
albúmina y luego se arrojan al torrente
sanguíneo donde
y realizan otras funciones hasta que
necesiten ser recuperadas por el hígado
para ser descompuestas o utilizadas para
otras macromoléculas el otro proceso
importante del que es responsable el
hígado se llama desintoxicación y este
es uno de esos asombrosos términos
científicos donde la función está en el
nombre aquí es donde tomamos las toxinas
y las modificamos para que no puedan
dañar nuestro cuerpo esto se logra
principalmente mediante las enzimas del
citocromo p450 que a diferencia de otras
que probablemente has escuchado antes no
se unen a un sustrato o molécula
específica si recuerdas una enzima como
la fenilalanina hidroxilasa es algo que
añadir a un grupo hidroxilo a la
fenilalanina y sólo a la fenilalanina
pero el citocromo p450 tomará muchos
sustratos diferentes para reaccionar con
ellos eso es algo bastante especial en
esta clase de enzimas ahora debido a
estas enzimas del citocromo p450 tenemos
un problema cuando
los medicamentos de hecho tenemos una
disminución en la eficacia del fármaco
debido a este proceso de desintoxicación
lo que entendemos por eficacia
farmacológica es la cantidad de efecto
que un medicamento puede tener de modo
que hacia el hígado o estas enzimas
perciben los medicamentos que ingerimos
como toxinas extrañas o similares van a
intentar acabar con ellos para que no
causen un efecto en nuestro cuerpo los
médicos lo saben y por eso deben
administrar una dosis específica de
medicamento que incluya la cantidad que
va a ser desintoxicada por el hígado y
finalmente como hablaremos en otro vídeo
con más detalle lo último que el hígado
hace es responsable de la producción de
bilis y como recordarán en nuestra
discusión sobre el intestino delgado la
bilis es necesaria para la absorción de
lípidos de nuestros alimentos bien ahora
que entendemos cuáles son las funciones
principales del hígado cómo se obtienen
todos los nutrientes que ingerimos y
absorbemos en nuestro tracto
gastrointestinal para ser metabolizados
almacenados o desintoxicados en el
hígado bueno echemos un vistazo al
suministro de sangre al hígado así que
una de las cosas que hace que el hígado
sea tan especial es que tiene dos
suministros de sangre separados el
primero que viene del tracto intestinal
es de la vena porta el sistema venoso
portal es otro término para ello y la
vena porta suministra al hígado sangre
rica en nutrientes rica en nutrientes
entonces de dónde vienen estos
nutrientes bueno los alimentos que se
absorben en el tracto intestinal pasarán
por la circulación y terminarán en la
vena porta para ser entregados al hígado
para el metabolismo por lo que
consideramos que esta sangre es rica en
nutrientes pero de dónde obtiene el
hígado su oxígeno bueno esa es una
fuente de sangre separada y en realidad
es a través de la arteria hepática
propia la arteria hepática propia y como
su nombre indica esta es sangre arterial
que estará suministrando glóbulos rojos
ricos en oxígeno muy bien estas son dos
de las diferentes fuentes
sangre que van al hígado qué pasa con la
sangre que sale del hígado hay un vaso
principal que transporta la sangre fuera
del hígado y se llama vena hepática la
vena hepática es exactamente lo opuesto
a los otros dos tipos de vasos de los
que acabamos de hablar es pobre en
nutrientes y oxígeno la sangre que sale
por la bne hepática del hígado circulará
de regreso al corazón para recibir
oxígeno fluirá más allá de los
intestinos para recibir nutrientes y
luego regresará al hígado ya sea a
través de la vena porta oa través de la
arteria hepática propia la otra salida
del hígado que supongo que debería
mencionar en este momento hablaremos con
más detalle en un vídeo separado es la
bilis y la bilis abandona principalmente
el hígado a través de lo que se llama el
conducto hepático común que llevara
bilis